Moscow has shattered the calm in the
capital
this house or what's left of it is in a
suburb south of Kiev City Center
hit by the falling wreckage of an
intercepted Russian missile
even though a majority of missiles have
been intercepted what you see here is a
crater made by a falling Warhead that
detonated and destroyed this house now
this wreckage is a symbol of the fact
that even though there has been a period
of calm Kiev is still a major Target for
Moscow
foreign
foreign
this comes off to the Russian defense
Ministry announced earlier this week
that a Ukrainian drone had targeted key
Airbase angles for the second time
Ukrainian officials say that all 16
missiles fired at the Kiev region were
intercepted but the mayor tells us that
the residents of the city may be
resilient but are very angry the
Russians want to bring depression
especially right now Christmas time New
Year the the Russians want to bring us
to to Black time to without lighting to
without heating they have to bring the
depression mood to everyone instead them
Ukrainian people very angry and they
told better we stay without electricity
without hitting but we never give up
after symbolic gains by Ukraine Russian
retaliation followed
an expected
war game
where the civilians always lose
Sky News Kiev